the second cover story we did for art
view which was in 2013 doubled the
membership of work view and the people
were just flooding into the space and
that was 2013 so we were we were really
coming from the sense of patient
advocacy and now I'm a three-time cancer
survivor and so I come to this as an
activist and an advocate this is a
political initiative that we've been
working on since January with two top
lobbyists in the beltway one's a
Republican once a Democrat you've taken
it on both sides of the aisle and it's
not just about cannabis it's about this
gender inequality of capital resources
as well so that's just one example of
many you have to have those 60 labs at
the table to say here's here's our pain
touch point here's what we see that it
needs to happen the cost is too high the
equipment's too high our time turnaround
is too slow I mean we have to address
all these things so that we can have a
robust market ending a safe supply chain
to the consumer so we have a big black
market problem still and it's affecting
everyone's opinion about the safety of
consumer products however as a you know
cancer survivor and as a big community
of people that I have used cannabis for
their wellness during their treatments
we know that lab tested compliant retail
dispensaries especially here in
California we know the responsible
actors and we know the responsible
brands as patients and we've continued
to be loyal to those risks because we
know that they have done their due
diligence and their years and millions
of dollars of product development
someone's opinion me contradict yours
where is my friend Allen it's all about
your perspective
who are we in what is the nature of this
reality what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host now and
succulent we are on site at the new West
Summit the cannabis tech conference
we're now going to be speaking with
gaynelle Rogers are you hi how are you
we're standing up the end of the day I'm
so excited we've done both done a great
job today yeah thank you so for our
conversation to Kino was named influence
of the Year in 2018 by industry power
women she's also a national
international expert in trusted media
source since 2009 in the cannabis
industry with 20-plus years in music and
film as well as activists in advocacy
work I'm so excited to talk there's so
much stuff here in the bio all right you
know let's start things off by asking
you you know who are you what do you
represent and why is it important for
other people to care Wow well the big
stuff have big stuff and that I like the
big stuff so I have been in the cannabis
space for 11 years I was recruited by a
tech H I recruiter to Harborside and C
D'Angelo and then the steep hill
laboratories and ArcView and worked with
other brands like the farm in Boulder so
I've had a I had a real pick of the
litter out of the gate got lucky but
there was no one doing what I did in
2009 which was marketing through media
relations through book deals and TV and
film nobody had that experience I was a
at the time a twice cancer survivor I am
now a three-time cancer survivor so
Steve and I were a perfect fit for
patient advocacy at the time we really
were a great team
and it was messaging this messaging out
to the national media in a way that we
were breaking stigmas I was literally
writing groceries for The Wall Street
Journal on the cannabis industry to the
health and science reporters to the
Discovery Channel when we were trying to
sell weed wars through Chuck Braverman
on that show who would produced that
show for the Discovery Channel that was
2010 was early first making glossaries I
was making glossary because because you
know I'd watch the evening news I'm a
news junkie I always have been always
will be and people using the word pot
and weed and mary-jane nobody was using
cannabis nobody was using medical Pat
compassionate nobody was using the terms
that we use now the National you see was
a patient advocacy it was a caregivers
oh they didn't know what it meant and
they weren't taking the time so we went
through health and science reporters
first as a strategy then when our feet
started to roll we went through the
finance system because we didn't have
banking cash management was a big
problem and we needed to address these
issues head-on to really solid
journalists who had a peak of an
interest maybe I'd written about it long
ago or had a little mention in a column
so alongside my wizard assistant Erica
Glenn we picked through all these big
media databases to find the writers the
real journalists that we thought would
get it that was very key and you depart
for journalists that you thought would
get it yes because it wasn't like just
take me through the assignment desk that
wasn't going to work we had to identify
the journalist that was going to get it
so I think that helped us create a
larger lens and broad breadth stroke
because I had a knack and also
experience of working with big-time
media through film studios and music
studios and knew that that was not going
to work but I also leveraged that I also
called my buddies and musical films that
I'm doing this now who on the staff you
think are going to dig this right so it
was it was kind of like really drilling
down on the right
journalist so it was very important to
make that difference
there are storytellers the communicators
because I worked with big feature films
it was all story arc story arc story arc
story arc no fluff so we were extremely
successful so who so I was first in my
field to actually do that work and and
and had Steve do some media training
with some professional actors I will not
name and off but also he was also so
such a natural and after a while I've
worked with a lot of thought leaders in
a lot of different field for the fields
and after really about the first month
or two I could sense that he was the
real deal that just needed to sharpen
his toolbox and we we were really a
great team in crafting these messages
and practicing and body language and
tonality and yes I asked him to cut the
braids off and get a Richard Branson
kind of look and he said no don't ask me
again but I had to ask one that's right
so the said that that would became I
kind of first to market first
CNN piece first TV show first New York
Times cover story first Fortune magazine
cover story and then we were soaring I
mean we had literally hundreds of
international and national journalists
through Harborside and then the second
cover story we did for art view which
was in 2013 doubled the membership of
art view and people were just flooding
into the space and that was 2013 so we
were we were really coming from the
sense of patient advocacy and now I'm a
three-time cancer survivor and so I come
to this as an activist and an advocate
yeah but I'm also have a very sharp
toolkit with me too I have a knack I'm
still a source I talked to the networks
all the time now for any particular
clients because I'm focusing on tree
house global ventures which I'll talk
about in a second but because I became a
trusted source what you know this vape
pen thing I got hit up super and I had
to
really work hard with CBS News for a
couple of stories that were incorrectly
reported some of this work in media
relations are marketing through media as
you please the media and if they report
something really wrong you you just very
politely correct them I have done
corrections in every major daily and
every network in the country just and
they were appreciate it it's it's this
story arc you were you you subliminally
made it gangsta by just using this
language you know oh you know you're
right I mean it was just very subtle
stuff like that
yeah so you know fast forward into this
one print before before we get there
just I'm just following what you're
describing it's this you know this like
this wave that's coming with us emerging
cannabis market and you're here helping
make sure that the stories are actually
getting communicated in the way that is
educational in the way that's authentic
in the way that communicates valuable
experiences of health and wellness being
augmented by cannabis and finding the
right distribution channels journalists
you know TV series all these different
kinds of media but I also had you know
20-plus experience doing this for
sometimes very difficult subject matters
and feature films or sometimes music
recordings that weren't quite so popular
but had a very meaningful message at the
time so and also I did a lot of advocacy
work and publicity in social justice
causes like music literacy and also
missing children so I did some very hard
news cases as well and I pride myself as
a New Orleans girl that I have so much
serendipity in my life
I was born in New Orleans and I have a
knack of being at the right place at the
right time and having the right tool kit
it's just been a blessing and I think
there's a reason for that because I'm
from New Orleans I believe in everything
and so I think that this next generation
of my life this mark I want to make
came to fruition when with other women
investors at ArcView that became friends
and mentors in the financial systems to
me my co-founders of treehouse Lindy
Snyder and Laurie Ferrara we all just
looked at each other about two years ago
and said you know there's no fun for
women and minorities that if there's all
these big funds that have all these
different focuses
but women traditionally get less than 2%
of any capital resources and women of
color and people of color get less than
0.5% of access to the 1% of wealth it's
really a political cultural black hole
ok so as this emerging market takes off
and there's people investing and making
money that all this wealth that's
created by these new advances that
happen by far the vast majority that's
going to men and also people that are
white correct ok and then it's been it's
so interesting again and again that
comes up the internet was one that was
supposed to do this blockchain and
decentralization technology's supposed
to do this cannabis and psychedelics
again supposed to do this but and now
our numbers are slipping women and
minorities I mean we were doing great at
2:15 2015 2016 and then at the end of
2016 with all these mas coming from
Canada and a lot of merge and a lot of
multi-state operators I'm trying not to
talk in acronyms because I've been
hearing it all day I believe that you
know somehow that larger money and
finance system came in and for some and
quickly and people were very excited oh
my goodness there's some of these huge
acquisitions and somehow in 2016 2017
2018 women and minorities weren't part
of that picture although I will say it's
now coming back up a little bit I just
met with a couple of women CEOs in New
York last week that are you know running
multi-state operations and they're doing
great but they have to fight for the
women in their c-suite and on their
board and so and they can
from tech or they came from cosmetics or
they came from in a big retail big-box
retail so they're very experienced
people and I realized that this is the
mist of main vision and information of
triage it's the mission and the purpose
to focus the lens on the lack of capital
resources and how the lack of access to
any capital resources any kind of
funding whatsoever in that top 1% the
billions and billions of dollars by the
way that have not hit us yet that is
institutional and VC they're not here
yet family offices here hedge funds here
private equity funds like tree house
global ventures here but that big big
top-line billions and billions of
dollars I have a friend that works at a
huge institution that manages three
hundred and thirty billion dollars of
wealth management globally and that
space has not touched this space and so
they ought they are watching and they're
looking so we I think even though we
have a lot of market disruption right
now there's a lot of money that's not
here yet as the federal regulatory
platform gets more clear which it will
whether it's this administration or the
next it will get clearer yeah FDA is
coming HIPAA compliance is coming we
know that so we feel that the market
conditions are a little dicey right now
but look at what's happening in like the
Midwest look what's happening in
Arkansas Missouri and Oklahoma they're
soaring these new adopting states
smaller states regional markets there's
going to be some really great brand
management because those people are
Midwestern they're gonna roll up their
sleeves go back to traditional marketing
and branding and put their firms stake
in their brown for their brands so I I
feel like the southeast and the Midwest
has been a little bit ignored and with
the new adoption and I think there's a
lot of investment opportunity there so
so yes I know the stock market has been
very volatile because of over evaluation
of our projections over you know not
meeting performers not not doing the
touch pulse of milestones required as
you get your trenches if you
three to five million dollar drop
whatever it is but I still am optimistic
and I still think this is early and this
is what happened in the Silicon Valley
exactly this rock and roll so treehouse
was formed to make this mark this
message this purpose and I feel I have a
big part of that for my nieces and
nephews and my daughter frankly I'm
doing it really for them
yes it's next-generation wealth
opportunity yes and I came up you know
bootstrapped with everything and and
made my way and did very very well but
those my nieces and nephews and daughter
and friends they graduated in 2008 they
couldn't find a job for two years so
they had part-time job four or five
prior times I mean it was rough on them
because they were sold that get that Ivy
League you know education and go to
college and you know it's gonna add to
your value and they graduated with all
their this debt and they couldn't find a
job for two years so and they came up
also after the 9/11 environment so they
choose their brands and they choose
their loyalty on mission and values yeah
and it's only going to continually gonna
continue in that direction so the
companies that we're looking at we will
we'll reach our first cap in probably a
month and we'll deploy our first
investment by the end of the year that's
pretty fast because we just started in
May so so so because we have so much
support because we we struck a chord
here so I think that and I'm bringing
all those nieces and nephews and my
daughter and her friends on the they're
on the watch list you know watch this
you're gonna learn from it this is how
you build an industry this is how you
build the brick and mortar you roll up
your sleeves you do traditional
marketing strategy and tactics I asked a
company the other day who were another
fund that I am helping advise for a
one-year to 18-month marketing and sales
strategy and she said what do I need
that for
and I said well how are you gonna
demonstrate you've asked for several
million dollars well the markets
changing so fast how can I write that I
said I get it but we want to know how
you will implement how are you getting
from A to Z your projections are 30%
more every quarter new industry does
that in any market environment that's
certainly not in this political
environment so go back and look at your
projections go back and look at your
evaluation and write that marketing and
sales strategy in this market
temperature in this disruptive
temperature and tell me how you're gonna
get there because she was she was
evaluated at fifteen million dollars and
it was just didn't make any sense
so pinch them then the stepping stones
the real touch points and the pain
points I want to know what you know
about your competitors about what they
did wrong what they did right and how
are you going to get to these kinds of
projections strategy and so yeah write
it so I can see that you have that part
of stage you're authoring your business
towards success there's another really
key component that we must hit on here
in the short bit of time we have and
it's just that this industry along with
all these other ones that we listed
earlier that's an emerging market right
now and you give these these big funds
of hundred plus billion dollar size
funds the question is about how to
democratize and distribute the benefits
the fruits of these emerging markets
like cannabis what would you say
obviously with what you're doing a tree
house you know bringing in the
perspective for people that are not
white for women this is huge and so the
is this one of the many diverse ways to
do so and how do we make inclusive steak
holding in the cannabis industry so that
other people that are that typically
don't see the benefits of massive
emerging markets like this actually do
finally well that's why we also going to
invest not only here but globally in
other technologies and things that
actually won't probably have anything to
do with the cannabis industry we want to
bring in talent and innovation that
might aid a few five years from now a
very robust cannabis industry and these
people don't want to touch the plant
they don't want to have anything to do
with it but they're coming from big tech
companies and they are seeing that there
is a big black hole we think we have the
technology platforms and the data
systems in this industry we do not in my
opinion you don't li not Google or Holly
Baba scale not Nielsen not SoundScan not
you know not measurements I was consumer
data like we did in film where we knew
the 12 to 14 year old what he ate what
he watched what do you wore what he
listened to we knew everything about
that movie consumer at that age so I
think it's really important to note that
the the data companies that are kind of
three to five years in I think they're
doing a good job but they're far from
what Nielsen SoundScan can tell us about
consumer behaviors so all that
technology needs to be innovated for our
particular industry and the security of
patient data because mote we only have
11 adult you States right
the rest are medically compassionate and
it's predicted by lobbyists and others
that particularly the southeast will
remain medical compassionate that they
will never go adult use and so we need
to you know maybe we have half and half
half medical compassionate half adult
views and we'll see what happens in
November there's a lot more on porting
states in November a lot of initiatives
on the November ballot this year and
next but I think that all of that 30,000
foot view is important to remember as an
investor and as somebody that is smart
educated and cares about an industry
that is really about in my view health
and wellness and a life choice it's not
for everybody I always tell everyone
that cannabis is not for everyone it's
not just for the sick it's not the stuff
everyone maybe air or water I keep
telling people I got you know it may not
be for you but I'm telling you even
three years ago nobody would sit by me
at dinner now everybody wants to sit by
me at dinner you know they didn't even
want to talk a lot about it I'd go back
home in Louisiana and I was raised in
Florida my dad was a NASA guy and nobody
wanted to talk out loud about it now
they do now they feel comfortable so
that's shifted in the last three or four
years which is great
I wonder what specific protocols are
going to be most crucial whether it be
on the competent torque potentials of
businesses that are made or of the
regulations that are pieced together
across different countries and what are
the best ways to make the benefits
democratized and to make it inclusive
that's gonna take some federal
regulatory work we are working with some
lobbyists and in the beltway on an
initiative to start to train the
communications officers of the hundred
women in Congress and the House and the
Senate and that's a start for messaging
because there they're not even talking
about it correctly come on Harris is not
even talking about it correctly none of
the candidates are talking about a
glossary you're gonna give them your
glossary I'm gonna redo the glossary for
the political temperature that we're in
and try to teach their communications
officers how to teach them how to talk
about it and we'll well it this is a
political initiative that we've been
working on since January with two top
lobbyists in the Beltway once a
Republican once a Democrat we've taken
it on both sides of the aisle and it's
not just about cannabis it's about this
gender inequality of capital resources
as well we couldn't just do cannabis we
tried and they said that's not gonna
work you know here's the other thing
because of the political environment one
of the very important senators said to
one of these lobbyists this is great I
think this will work I think you're
addressing some gender pay equity issues
wellness and lifestyle some health
regulatory compliance issues you know
we're talking about having a stake at
the table when they start to form these
regulations with the CDC and the FDA and
the DEA we want to be at the table yeah
and so they said but you know what
here's the honest-to-god truth this is
not at the top of everybody's list we
have so many issues to address in this
country you need to make it more
important in the health and wellness
message
the gender pay equity message in and
that this now that the banking thing is
as past the house someone said on the
investors okay in fact it's the safe
fact you know the so you want to marry
the health and wellness with the gender
equity stuff and then that will make it
more prominent on people's radars it has
to have more robust messaging for both
sides of the aisle to care yeah we have
to we have to tell them why they should
care and then we have to educate them
how to care and then how to talk about
it
and then what would you what would you
propose within that that the gender
equity and the cannabis what would you
want to happen on a regulatory level
from the arm what would be your ideal
scenario that's a hard question because
it's a very complex question you know
certainly there has to be some national
federal lab testing regulatory platform
I know that there's actually some French
Canadians that have talked to 60 labs
across the country and they want to help
form that regulation with all those
stakeholders that are on the front lines
of testing so that's just one example of
many you have to have those 60 labs at
the table to say here's here's our pain
touch points here's what we see that and
it needs to happen the cost is too high
the equipment's too high our time
turnaround is too slow I mean we have to
address all these things so that we can
have a robust market and a safe supply
chain to the consumer and with the
vaping crisis and that's got a big
question mark because we do know for a
fact as Leafly has reported and others
that a lot of those cartridges were
coming we're exact copies from China of
Jul and other other devices and so we
know that for a fact we know that three
of those deaths for a fact were because
of counterfeit cartridges and so it's
it's a it's actually a good thing that's
happened because that could have been a
huge consumer health crisis had they not
started and start to put on the brakes
and then there was a story about these
Minnesota that had like a million
dollars worth of fake cartridges
underneath their bed and it was like wow
came from China or Thailand or Indonesia
so you know and they're selling them for
five bucks when there are thirty dollars
an hour legal compliant dispensary
because the kids were just really into
this so we have a big black market
problem still and it's affecting
everyone's opinion about the safety of
consumer products however as a you know
cancer survivor and as a big community
of of people that have used cannabis for
their wellness during their treatments
we know that lab tested compliant retail
dispensaries especially here in
California we know the responsible
actors and we know the responsible
brands as patients and we continue to be
loyal to those brands because we know
that they have done their due diligence
and their years and millions of dollars
of product development these specific
things just constantly fascinates me
indigenous people have been for the
longest time just living on the land and
in being one with the different fruits
of that land and then there's this whole
idea of well when you're trying to
distribute to millions of people it has
to go through all these regulatory
frameworks for safety and then there's
that dichotomy between those two things
like if someone's you know distributing
to them and they're like three neighbors
in the woods something like a big
dichotomy between things like there's a
big guy kind of me but look Emerald
triangle perfect example eighty percent
of that product that was grown in
Mendocino and humble Connie's left the
state for thirty years eighty percent
look this up this is a fact yeah those
are numbers are massive massive yeah but
do people get sick were their deaths you
know where there was so hard to track of
course and and and this is the standard
like you said of lab testing things that
millions of people are consuming is
that's critical otherwise there will be
may big issues that have
yeah that's that's something that's the
I'm very interested in all the different
aspects that you listed of the different
because I wonder the good a decent
question would be would you say that the
same thing would be repeated in Latin
America and Africa and Europe and Asia
when I have it to treat safe safety for
their consumers as well so this has to
come from what I think is not just
pharmaceutical because that's so
expensive I actually think that this is
going to come from food safety and more
like natural food products and
nutriceuticals I think that might be the
the path FDA approved fur on and Lincoln
in a nutritional cry like right when you
intake this
cannabis vitamin D or tumeric er you
know a lot of our extractors and the
extracting machines came from AG
extraction and essential oil extraction
so when you think about the
nutraceutical and natural foods industry
remember the FDA Organic certification
only happened in the 70s and by the way
Maria rodale who's on our board a tree
house grandfather started that process
or Dale publishing men's health
Prevention magazine etc etc her
grandfather started that process as I
understand it and her father finished it
helped the FDA devise the criteria for
organic certification so I see that
coming and she's on our board and she's
just wonderful she's all about hemp and
sustainability and lifestyle and she
sold the family publishing company so
she's in publishing recovery but where
is she
so she's learning about the cannabis
industry and she's teaching us about all
the natural foods and nutraceuticals and
lifestyle choices is called the low
house market lifestyle and organic
natural foods association and this is a
huge billion billion dollar industry in
this country now and the Millennials are
following that path
look at what happened to be on meat look
what happened to vegan look what
happened to gluten-free these are all
wellness lifestyle choices we can get in
that line maître suitable --zz
interesting yeah okay let's wrap last
question is what do you think is the
most beautiful thing in the world
right now it's my house haven't seen it
two weeks we live on eight acres in the
nut Tahoe National Forest on a Ridge
it's very beautifully managed forest and
it's like living in a park yeah and it's
it's I sit on that porch and that is my
Zen I just sit on my porch swing
and just I'm so happy that I live in a
small little cultural town with lots of
arts benefits and good restaurants and
lots of culture and I just feel
extremely fortunate you know thank you
so much you're welcome
I can't wait for one moment let's close
the show thank you so much for tuning in
everyone we greatly appreciate it we'd
love to hear your thoughts in the
comments below in the episode let us
know what you're thinking thank you
check out all the links in the BAU below
to Gino's work also two treehouse
ventures check that out and also check
out the links in the bio to New West
summit as well check those out and also
support the artists the entrepreneurs
the leaders in your communities that you
believe and support them you can support
simulation our links are below as well
and go and build the future everyone
manifest your dreams into the world
thank you so much for tuning in and we
will see you soon
[Music]